into Shiva one of Japan's most famous
companies has warned it may not be able
to stay in business the company which
traces its origins to 1875 said it was
likely to report a fully a net loss of 8
billion pounds and it may yet be
delisted from the Tokyo Stock Exchange
because auditors have not been able to
sign off on its accounts it follows an
accounting scandal in 2015 and news last
month at Westinghouse its US nuclear
subsidiary has had to seek bankruptcy
protection a warning the following
pictures feature flash photography got a
mother covenant she thought I'd like to
offer my sincere apologies to all
stakeholders including shareholders and
investors for the trouble and concern we
have caused by delaying our financial
results and ending up in this situation
if the Tokyo Stock Exchange decides to
delist a company is obvious that it
thinks it will threaten the stability of
the market if it's not delisted
immediately so we'd like to make the
utmost effort to avoid delisting dr.
Yoshi katsu shintaro is a senior
lecturer in financial studies at the
School of Oriental and African Studies
so how did Toshiba find itself in this
position well it is a bit puzzle even
for the top management in Toshiba
the last December they just realized how
much loss they will make announced to
announce and the army clearly they've
had this accounting scandal in the
problem they clearly still have issues
with their auditors given that the
auditors are refusing at the moment to
sign off on the accounts but through the
the announcement they make today is not
audited the informally they announced so
we will see what's happened next so
anyone who buys the shares at the moment
is flying blind because there's no
health check if you like from the
accountants the announcement today is
not endorsed yet so we will see what
happened so Toshiba are going to try and
get around this by selling its memory
chip business which is the jewel in its
crown essentially it's not going to be
enough to get it out of difficulties
what depends on the area how must be a
potential buyer will pay for instance
one or two big Taiwanese corporation
they pay more than 321 billion pounds or
so then they are okay financially but
the question is what they're going to do
next what exactly I mean Shawn of the
memory chip business where does that
leave to
but what do they have left well the the
proportion of the memory chip business
is about one third of toast about the
business the remains are at the energy
business and also the a our electricity
of household or industries there are so
there some part of their business and
the unloads business I'm living inside
the energy business which is clearly in
a messy electronics businesses are
generally in fine shape are they well
the AR it is obvious the microchips
business is most profitable business but
however also they have some divisions to
run the air forklift or industry
machineries to there they make some
profit to but but the point is that the
chip business is the most profitable is
the most exciting long-term growth
prospects it would be a shame for them
to lose it that's very true yes that's
very true so I guess the big question is
do you think Toshiba can survive all
this that's that's a really really big
question for them I think it is it is at
the moment their priority is to survive
and to remain listed in the Tokyo Stock
Exchange over here in the UK of course
they've just acquired a 60% stake in new
gen which is going to build a new
nuclear power plant in in Moorside in
Cumbria what are the likelihood of that
going ahead do you feel to be honest I
have to not know what's happened next
with regard to the nuclear business
abroad in general because they're high
priority at the moment to survive now
the interesting thing is this is not the
first big Japanese companies who have
had accounting scandals Olympus a few
years ago very very high profile is
there something unique about Japanese
business that makes them prone to these
kind of scandals well that's interesting
point yes the a Japanese corporations
they promote globalized
corporate governor's however in reality
what you said is true in reality they
are behind the global standard with
regard to the corporate governance